how much can you explain to me about the
way that security clearance levels work
because I went down a Wikipedia Rabbit
Hole a while ago and couldn't really
work out and then there's Q level and
the tell me what you can about how that
works yeah so it's a very complicated
mess so I'll tell you what I understand
and and fully recognize that there's a
thousand people out there who are going
to disagree with me because they know
something else and that's totally cool
with me
so in large part secret secret clearance
is the foundation of it all it's the
lowest level of clearance
um sometimes you'll see things as
confidential or for official use only or
um different different other
subcategories but those categories
aren't really a clearance like you don't
walk around with a you know for your
eyes only level of clearance you either
walk around with no security clearance
or you walk around with a secret level
clearance
secret level clearances are actually so
common that there's something called a
provisional secret which means just by
applying for a secret level clearance
you get a secret level clearance and
it's called a provisional secret
clearance and you have it until you're
proven to be somebody that can't be
trusted so once you have that then all
the other clearances stack on top of
that so the first most logical one is
top secret top secret goes on top of
secret and top secret usually has to do
with uh with an an area or an element of
of sensitive information there's
definitions for all of them
um so if you can Google them to find out
these specific definitions for a level
of clearance right I think secret is it
could could potentially do damage to
National Security top secret is could do
grave damage to National Security right
and then uh out inside of your top
secret top secret becomes a bucket with
multiple different verticals
sometimes when I was in the military
there's a special compartment
information SCI tssci that has different
categories when I was in nuclear weapons
with the military those nuclear weapons
specific categories were cat 6 and Cat
12. the other 10 categories related to
different things aircraft
nuclear submarines movements of troops
you know tank weapons anti-aircraft
weapons whatever it might be inside CIA
we have further subcategories that have
to do with human intelligence so you
might have a human intelligence security
category that is specific to
counter-narcotics or specific to counter
proliferation or specific to
Russian operations inside of Russia
Russian operations outside of Russia it
gets super compartmentalized and the
more the deeper into the rabbit hole you
go the more you get that compartments
compartmentalization all of your like
I've also heard of Q clearances
cue clearances I think are specific to
the military I think they have to do
with with the people who actually create
codes that become the foundation for
communication and for nuclear codes and
nuclear launch sequences
um I'm very likely wrong but I do know
that a q code a q clearance is a real
clearance it's not just from the X-Files
wow and so we kind of have the same
thing again that we talked about that
almost hourglass shape with regards to
um your level of public exposure also
must happen here in that you start off
with a very low but incredibly broad
type of clearance you can see everything
that is secret that's not much in terms
of the height but that's everything in
terms of the breadth you get through top
secret and then you begin to
compartmentalize and you have the
different numbers or you have the
different subcategories but then
presumably the director and the
president the president has the most
high level of clearance that's possible
because he has to be able to see
everything across all levels of
clearance now imagine that even the
president must be compartmental against
certain things that he doesn't need to
know perhaps right now
yeah I'm sorry to interrupt go ahead
Chris just that it's this same situation
again right that you can implementalize
in and then you brought the broaden back
out again yeah you know it's interesting
when you when you use that example it's
a very interesting example
um there are two things that kind of
that add context to it right the first
is that the higher the tighter the
compartmentalization goes the stricter
the archive and data management process
becomes so you know a secret piece of
information might literally be written
on a piece of paper and might just get
handed from person to person with a
little rubber stamp that says secret on
it and that's pretty much all the all
the positive control you have and
somebody might accidentally drop it in
the trash can or light it on fire or you
know whisk it away and give it to the
Russians who knows
but when you're getting to those super
compartmentalized pieces of information
like you're talking about with the
president every piece of that data is
archived it's strictly monitored there's
you know backup against contingency
against secondary and tertiary
monitoring so that if any of those
pieces of information are ever leaked
they can be reverse engineered to find
out where the leak is because for
example we would never suspect the
president of being the person who leaks
information I know there are some
conspiracy theorists out there who
suspect exactly that but that we could
actually track back the data points to
see was it the president was it the
briefer because every piece of
information the president gets comes
from a briefer was it the person who
wrote the article that went into the
president Daily Brief because everybody
there's a human being who writes that
there's a human being who carries the
president's Daily Brief to the Oval
Office every day that person just that
person could open that book and start
flipping away pages and taking pictures
on honest on their cell phone for all we
know right so all of that information is
really heavily guarded and monitored so
that they can reverse engineer and find
out where the leak is if a leak is ever
identified is this a combination of
physical and digital security then
because presumably the I know the
president's Daily Briefing is this
binder type scenario that gets handy to
him that's something physical right
those are pieces of paper with words
printed on them correct going further
back from that there will be different
types of encryption that will be
tracking on the encryption there will be
ways to work out has this I'm going to
guess that maybe tied in with the NSA or
something you may even be able to have a
way to search for like plagiarism at
University does this appear on the web
anywhere web scraping to see if
something matches something that was in
the daily briefing okay where's this
come from so there must be a very
complex
um combination of security protocols
going on here yeah for sure and I don't
think any of us are really again when it
comes to level of clearance there's no
need to know I had no need to know how
they protect the president's daily but
somebody out there does have that need
to know and that person would know
exactly how it's protected but you are
correct in in your assessment that
there's both a mix of digital and
physical Securities on the physical side
we call it positive control
positive control means you don't only
have one person in control of something
you actually have two people in control
of something so if you or I are carrying
a briefcase with something sensitive in
it positive control does not mean you
have the briefcase positive control
means you and I together have the
briefcase maybe you're the one that has
it in your hands but I'm right beside
you at all times maybe I'm the one that
has it in my hands but you're right
beside me at all times so at the end of
the day two people can vouch for every
step that that document or that that
code may have taken that's positive
control on the physical side and then
you've got all the digital controls
because your clearance and your role uh
dictate what you actually have access to
within a digital system it's not that
different from Corporate America you
can't be a salesperson and log in to the
accounting side of the software you
can't be an accountant and log into the
sales customer management tool so
there's there's digital and physical
elements that go into protecting
everything from the documents uh all the
way to you know who the primary top 10
terrorist targets are that are going to
get neutralized this week I'm going to
guess as well that makes any
infiltration or turning of assets going
to be much harder because you don't just
need to get the one person you need to
get the second person to correct yeah
everything's there because when we talk
about you know positive control and
physical security what we're really
protecting against is it's it's
Espionage we're protecting against an
internal Insider threat a mole uh an
officer that gets turned over we've seen
that and we've seen how devastating it
can be so now you know everything we're
doing is excessive security again on the
security and convenience very secure not
very convenient it can seem archaic that
in the modern day
you're still carrying around a printed
binder right remember when uh when uh
President Obama insisted on having a
Palm Pilot that got that had Security on
it
um there's just there's really funny
stuff that we just never think of what's
Happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]
oh